The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOANNE STUBBE: Hi.
Today, what we're going to do
is focus on yet another cofactor
that you get out of
your vitamin bottle.
And today we're going to
be looking at vitamin B6.
And vitamin B6 is the cofactor
that you use whenever you
want to metabolize amino acids.
Where do you get amino acids?
We all eat proteins.
The proteins get
degraded to amino acids.
And we can use the
energy released.
And trap that energy
to do bio synthesis.
And we use amino acids, convert
them into central metabolism,
and use them to make
fats, or sugars, depending
on what the environment is
telling us we need to do.
So let me introduce
you to this cofactor,
the vitamin itself, as you have
seen now, over and over again,
is not the actual cofactor.
It's Pyridoxine.
And so that's what you eat
out of the vitamin bottle.
And as in the case of
all vitamins, inside
the cell it has to be
converted into the active form
of the cofactor.
And the cofactor we're
going to be talking about,
the active form is Pyridoxal
phosphate, which is called PLP.
And the structure of pyridoxal--
there two main structures
of the pyridoxal phosphate
cofactor, one of them
is involved in 80%
of all the chemistry.
And the one we're going
to talk about today,
uses both forms of the cofactor.
That fits into
central metabolism.
I'll show you how
that fits in a minute.
So pyridoxal phosphate
has this structure.
You have a pyridine
ring, the pKa.
The pyridine ring is 6 5, so it
may or may not be protonated.
And the key part of
the cofactor-- one
of the key parts of the
cofactor, is this aldehyde.
So pyridoxal means that
this is an aldehyde.
The second form of the
cofactor is pyridoxamine.
So this aldehyde
is somehow-- and we
will look at how
this happens-- is
converted from this aldehyde,
into an amino group.
And this is called PMP,
or pyridoxamine phosphate.
Now the other thing
I wanted to show you,
before we move on
to look at more
details of pyridoxal
phosphate, is-- while this
is the form of the vitamin.
You almost never see this
form inside the cell.
It is always bound in the
active site of the enzyme.
And it binds in the active
site of the enzyme--
so here's your enzyme--
through the epsilon
amino group of a lysine.
So you never really, when
you purify the protein,
you never isolate the aldehyde.
So this is the aldehyde.
And I won't draw out all
the rest of the structure,
but what you have
is an amino group,
that's attached to a lysine, in
the active site of your enzyme.
And what we're going to
do is convert this ketone
into an imine.
So this is chemistry you see
over and over and over again.
You've seen it already
with carbonyl chemistry,
with carbon-carbon
bond forming reactions,
with peptide bond hydrolysis,
that we've already
talked about.
But what you do is, you're
going to convert this aldehyde
into an imine.
You need to go through a
tetrahedral intermediate.
And the carbonyl is polarized,
delta plus, delta minus.
You spend a lot
of time practicing
this kind of chemistry to form
a tetrahedral intermediate.
And I'm going to have
a proton transfer.
So one of the things that's
tricky about this chemistry
is that, if you count
the number of protons
they move around a lot
in the active site.
And the fact is, that you
want to protonate something
to make it into a
better leaving group,
you want to
deprotonate something
to make it function
more like a nucleophile,
or as a base, and
nature has figured out
how to orchestrate all the
residues in the active site
to do this.
In most cases, we don't
understand all of the details.
And so I'm not going to
focus on proton transfer,
but you're going to see
many proton transfers
within the active site.
So this gives us a tetrahedral
intermediate, or transition
stage.
You've seen that
over and over again.
And now what will
happen is that you want
to lose a molecule of water.
So again, you need to pronate
that, and what you form then
is a new carbon doubly
bonded to a nitrogen,
rather than doubly
bonded to the oxygen,
that's covalently
bound to the enzyme.
And so, this is called an imine.
And because it's an
imine of an aldehyde,
it's called an aldimine.
So whenever you isolate
your enzyme, whenever
you isolate your
enzyme, the pyridoxal
is always covalently bound.
OK, so, this bond is
chemically easy to hydrolyze,
but it's always
covalently bound.
OK.
So what I want to do now, is
make a few generalizations
about pyridoxal, but the first
thing is, that in all cases,
whenever you metabolize-- I want
to metabolize an amino acid.
Pyridoxal phosphate
requiring enzyme
is going to be the key player.
OK.
So here's an amino acid.
OK, here's the alpha
position, the beta position,
and the gamma position.
Well what's so amazing--
I remember first hearing
about this-- is that
you can do chemistry
at all these positions.
And the way nature
figures out how
to do this is by
orchestrating the active site,
with acid based catalyst sitting
around in the right place,
to allow you to do the
chemical transformation
that this protein
has evolved to do.
So let me to show you
what the alpha position,
so this is the alpha position,
you can cleave this bond.
I'll show you how this happens.
You can do all this chemistry
with a few simple chemical
transformations, takes practice,
but once you sort of get
what these
transformations are, it's
amazing what you can get
this cofactor to help you do.
And I'll explain
that in a minute.
So you get cleavage of
the carbon carbon bond
that's loss of CO2 that's
a decarboxylation reaction.
We don't talk about that in
507, but that kind of reaction
generates all of our
neurotransmitters.
You're going to cleave
this carbon-hydrogen bond.
Remember, amino acids are
in the S configuration--
but for example in
cell wall, in bacteria,
they can be either the S
or the R configuration,
so you can cleave that bond,
and put the proton back
on the other face, that's
a racemization reaction.
You can cleave this
carbon-carbon bond
between the alpha and
the beta position,
that's a reaction-- remember, we
talked about carbon-carbon bond
formation-- this is the
reverse aldol reaction.
And the one where we're going
to focus on today, which
is the one that fits best
into central metabolism,
is what happens to this
carbon-nitrogen bond.
So we have an amino
group of our amino acid
is going to get converted
into a ketone group.
So, this group, is going to
get converted into this group.
And to do that, we're going
to use the imine of pyrodoxial
phosphate that we have in the
active site of the enzyme.
So this is sort
of like a carbonyl
and that's going
to get converted
into the amine,
the pyridoxamine.
So these are the two
forms of the cofactor.
So what are we going
to be focusing on, is
how this reaction,
actually, happens, and this
is the most complicated of
all the pyridoxal prostate
dependent reactions.
So that I'm going to come
back to this in a minute,
but what I want to do is
make a few generalizations
about where you're going to see
pyridoxal phosphate chemistry
in primary metabolism.
So what we're going to
see is that the TCA cycle,
tricarboxylic acid cycle,
or the Krebs cycle,
plays a central role.
It's found in the mitochondria.
You're going to see this
over and over again,
over the course of the semester.
Things feed in and
out of the cycle.
A cycle means it goes
around and around,
and if you remove
something from the cycle
and don't put anything back
into the cycle, the cycle stops.
And you're in serious trouble.
So one way-- one thing--
one way to feed in and out
of this cycle is
through amino acids.
So this reaction,
which we're going
to call the transemination,
or a transamination,
is metabolism of
amino acid, we'll
see into an alpha keto acid.
So if you look at
the TCA cycle and we
look at this reaction,
what you'll see
is you have this compound,
called alpha ketoglutarate.
OK, so alpha
ketogluterate and that
going to interconvert
with the amino acid
and so this ketone is
going to be converted
into an amino
group, and so we're
having the amino group
converted into a ketone group.
And pyridoxial is going to be
converted into pyridoxamine.
So we're going to have
PLP converted into PMP.
I'm going to show
you how that works.
So, if you feed in
glutamate from your diet,
it-- by this pyridoxal
phosphate dependent reaction--
can feed into the Krebs cycle.
If you want to make amino
acids, on the other hand,
you can suck some of
the alpha keto acid
out, and convert it
into amino acids.
And you have to have a way
of controlling whether you
feed in, or you, actually,
remove your metabolites
from the cycle.
If you come up here and look at
oxaloacetic and aspartic acid--
So oxaloacetic acid is also
an alpha keto acid, OK.
And the amino
acid-- can you see?
I'm probably too close
to the edge-- OK,
and so here we have
the amino acid.
So here we have amino acid alpha
keto acid, amino acid alpha
keto acid.
If you go further up
and go pyruvate feeds
into the TCA cycle--
pyruvate comes
from the glycolysis
pathway, which
again is breakdown of sugars,
pyruvate is an alpha keto acid.
So this is a CH3, so
this is the simplest,
and this can get
interconverted into alanine.
So what you see is this same
theme-- amino group ketone,
amino group ketone.
I'm being sloppy, here.
Most amino groups
are protonated,
because the pKa, you should
remember, is around 9.
So they're, mostly,
protonated in solution.
I should protonate this
over here, as well.
And so you have a ketone
group and amino group.
So this is called
anaplerotic pathways
where things can feed in and
feed out of central metabolism.
And this is the only time,
during the course of 507,
that you're introduced
to amino acids,
and how they're metabolized.
So what I want to
do now is then,
briefly, show you how this
transformation, actually,
works.
OK.
So I'm going to give
you some general rules.
So the transformation
I just showed you--
an amino acid into an alpha keto
acid-- looks to be complicated.
And, I told you, the cofactor
changes its structure
from an imine into
an amino group.
And the question is,
how does that happen?
So I want to show you a
bunch of simple, basic rules
that allow you to think
about all pyridoxal phosphate
requiring chemistry.
So I'm going to
write down the rules,
and then I'm going
to show you how
it works on the
reactions we were just
looking at this these
transeminations,
or transamination reactions.
So how do we think about the
mechanism of these PLP enzymes?
So the first thing
is-- the first step
is-- so you're going to
start out with an imine bound
to the active site of
your pyridoxal phosphate
and an amino acid.
I'll abbreviate it aa.
And the first thing you
do is, you're going to,
remove this imine and form a
new imine with the amino acid.
So that's called a
transimination reaction, OK.
So what we're going to
do is form a new imine.
And so the imine
from the amino acid,
and I'll show you
how this happen,
is going to switch
with this one.
And so what you're left
with, in the active site,
is the amino group
of the lysine.
OK.
So this lysine--
nature has figured out
how to minimize the
numbers of acid and base
groups constrained in the
region, the active site, where
all the chemistry happens.
And she uses this lysine, which
initially is holding covalently
the cofactor, in
the active site.
She then uses this lysine to
do general acid, general base
catalysis.
And she uses it over
and over and over again.
Now every pyridoxal
enzyme is distinct
and has additional groups
in the active site.
But we know a lot
about this chemistry.
We even know what
the groups are,
but we're going to look and
talk about generalizations.
So the first thing,
we have to do
is, we need to free up
our general acid base
catalyst, lysine, and we
need to covalently bind
the amino acid, which is a
substrate, into pyridoxal.
So that's the first step.
And I'm going to come
back to this in a minute.
The second step in
all of these reactions
is-- all amino acids
have an alpha hydrogen,
that alpha hydrogen
has a very high pKa.
It's very hard for a normal
amino acid side chain,
in the active site,
to remove that proton,
because it's not acidic enough.
So what I'm going to
show you is pyridoxal
increases the acidity
of that alpha hydrogen,
making it easier to
do the chemistry.
So the second step in almost
all pyridoxal reactions,
is removal of the
alpha hydrogen.
And we can do that, because PLP
makes the hydrogen more acidic.
And I'll show you why
that's true in a minute.
And then, the third thing is,
once you remove that hydrogen,
then you get a look at the
chemistry you want to catalyze.
And we're going to be talking
about this transimination
transamination reactions.
But remember I told-- you can
do all this chemistry at alpha,
beta, gamma.
So you need to assess
what the substrate is,
and what the product is, and
then, within the active site,
you're going to have to
do a lot of manipulation
with acid and base
catalysts to get you
into the final stage, where
you can release the product you
want to release.
So the last step
in this reaction--
in all pyridoxal reactions-- so
we do some chemistry in here.
And I'll show you
what the chemistry is
with transamination reactions.
The word transimination
reactions-- now
I keep saying transamination
and transimination.
That's because most textbooks
call it transamination,
because they think about
pyridoxal as the aldehyde.
But, in reality, pyridoxal
is always in the imine,
covalently bound.
And so that's why it's that
transimination, rather than
a transamination.
So the last step
then, is, hydrolysis.
And I'll show you how that
happens, or transimination
to reform this structure.
So we get ourselves back
to where we started.
So there's three simple
steps, and in the middle,
depending on what the
reaction is, you have
to do additional manipulations.
But all pyridoxal enzymes
go through these three,
general steps.
The first step, I told
you, in all these reactions
is transimination.
OK.
So here's our Schiff-base,
and it's your pyridoxal.
It's covalently bound to the
lysine in the active site.
Now one thing that students
often find confusing
is the protonation
state of this imine.
And that's because it's right
around neutral pH, pH 7.
So depending on what's
in the active site,
it could be protonated,
or not protonated,
if it's protonated of course
it enhances reactivity
for nucleophilic attack.
So you want it to be protonated.
So the active site is
going to manipulate itself
to put in the protonated state.
So here you have an
amino acid, and here we
have a protonated imine, and
so this is the nucleophile,
and it can attack the
carbon of the imine
to form a tetrahedral adduct.
So that's what we're doing here.
So, this, is going
to attack, this,
to form this tetrahedral adduct.
And, you've seen
again, the tetrahedral
chemistry over again,
when I showed you
how you formed this
imine in the first place.
So tetrahedral chemistry,
tetrahedral intermediates,
transition states, which
collapse to form back
imines, or carbonyls, happens
over and over, and over again
in pyridoxal chemistry.
So now what happens is we have
this tetrahedral intermediate,
or transition state-- I have
it in parentheses, because it's
a high energy intermediate,
it doesn't sit around,
and let us look at it.
Most of the time you
can never see it.
It's very high on a
reaction coordinate.
This, collapses then,
and when it collapses,
what do you generate?
You generate the lysine
in the active site.
So now we have
generated a residue
in the active site
that can function
as a general acid,
or general base,
catalysis through the rest of
the chemical transformations.
And what've we done, is
we've converted this imine
with lysine, now to an
imine of the amino acid.
So that's what transimination
is, one imine to another imine.
The imine that's
covalently bound
to the protein through
pyridoxal, to an amino acid
imine.
OK, so, that's the first step.
The second step is
that ultimately,
in almost all pyridoxal
reactions, you
want to remove this
alpha hydrogen.
And that alpha hydrogen,
again, is extremely non-acidic
but by complexing the
amino acid to pyridoxal--
this is what the
function of the cofactor
is-- you are enhancing the
acidity of this alpha hydrogen.
You're making it easier for
a group in the active site,
a general base
catalyst, like lysine,
can now pull off this proton
to generate this intermediate.
Now why is this
hydrogen more acidic?
Well, if you look
at the structure,
you can draw all kinds
of resonance structures
which shows that this
carbanion is more stabilized,
because it's attached to
the pyridoxal cofactor.
So if you look at this, you can
draw this resonance structure,
which is shown here, and you
can draw 20 other resonance
structures.
OK, so, the key here is you
can remove the alpha hydrogen,
because you're
able to delocalize
these unpaired electrons on this
carbon over the entire system.
So let me show you
what that looks like.
So if I draw-- this is called
Dunathan's hypothesis-- so
here's our pyridine
ring, here's our imine,
and here's our amino acid.
Here's the carboxal-- here's
the side chain in our group
and here's a carboxylate, OK.
So the idea is, you have like
a benzene ring-- if you haven't
seen pyridine rings-- but
you have a pi cloud that
delocalizes-- where these
electrons are completely
delocalized over the
aromatic ring-- but here,
you also have a pi cloud
and these things are close
enough so you can delocalize.
Now what you're going to do--
and the way nature decides
what chemistry happens is since
we want to cleave, in this case
the carbon-hydrogen
bond, she places
that carbon-hydrogen bond--
by complexing the carboxylate
and complexing whatever
the R group is--
she places that
carbon-hydrogen bond
perpendicular to this plane
of the pi aldimine system.
So what you're doing then is the
lysine, that we just liberated
through doing the
transimination reaction,
you now generate
an empty P orbital
with unpaired electrons in
it, generate the carbanion
and now this system can
completely delocalize.
So, again, this
pyridine ring is planar.
So you can, completely,
delocalize the electrons
over this whole system.
This is a pi cloud.
And now this is already set up
so that it can delocalize over
this whole system.
So what you've done then
is because of the ability
to stabilize this
carbanion you're
making that hydrogen
more acidic.
So if you wanted to say, for
example, cleave-- remember,
I told you at the
very beginning,
you might be able to
decarboxylate-- that enzyme,
would place that
CO2 perpendicular
to the plane of the
pi aldimine system
and use the same strategy
to stabilize the resulting
carbanion intermediate.
We're not going to talk
about that chemistry in 507.
So what you've done then--
what the beauty of pyridoxal
is that she's
increased this acidity,
and allows you a great
deal of flexibility.
Because once you generate that
carbanion-- those of you who've
had 513-- you'll, immediately,
recognize if you have a leaving
group on a carbon
adjacent to this carbon,
you can do an
elimination reaction.
So it sets up a whole
series of transformations.
For today, were only focusing
on the transimination reaction.
How do we convert
this to an alpha keto
acid, and the pyridoxal
to pyridoxamine?
That's the question
we're asking.
So we do this chemistry.
And now what we need to do,
we can use this resonance
structure, we want to ask the
question, what is the product?
Well, we want to get
to an alpha keto acid.
OK, and if you look
at this structure,
this molecule is an imine
of an alpha keto acid.
So this is, exactly, the
state we want to be in,
but then we have
all of this-- we
have this reactive
intermediate here.
So what we want to do is
protonate some place here
to generate this state.
So that the last step in
all pyridoxal reactions
is hydrolysis.
And now we're set up with
the hydrolysis reaction
to generate the alpha keto acid.
So, we then want to
ask the question,
where can we protonate?
And, so, again, we
have this lysine
which we now have used
to pull off the alpha
hydrogen. It's now protonated.
So now instead of being
a general based catalyst,
here, it's functioning as
a general acid catalyst.
And so now what can
happen is you can pick up
a proton from this lysine, it's
supplying it with that proton,
to generate this
structure and regenerate
lysine that can function now
as a general base catalyst.
So it's toggeling between
general acid and general base
catalysis.
And now remember, what
we want to get in the end
is this pyridoxamine, and we
want this alpha keto acid,
and now we're set up to rapidly
go to an alpha keto acid.
Where have you seen
chemistry like this before?
You've seen it in
the aldolase reaction
that we talked about with
carbon-carbon bond forming
reactions.
So the last step in all PLP
dependent transaminations
is hydrolysis.
So here we have the lysine
acting as a general base
to activate water for
a nucleophilic attack
on this imine, which is
activated to have water add,
and now you form again, your
tetrahedral transition state.
I have all of these unstable
species in brackets.
We really-- sometimes we see
them, sometimes we don't.
But you have to work
hard to see them.
And now this simply,
the tetrahedral adduct,
collapses to form pyridoxamine
and forms the alpha keto acid.
So that's where
we wanted to get.
But now what happens, is we're
in the form of the cofactor--
instead of being in the aldehyde
form we're in the imine form.
So what we want to
do now is reverse
this reaction using a
different alpha keto acid,
and we will generate a
different amino acid.
So now what can happen-- so
in their pyridoxamine form,
we then can bind a
different alpha keto acid--
remember, in the
first slide, I showed
you three different
alpha keto acids--
oxaloacetic acid,
alpha-ketoglutarate,
pyruvate-- you can reverse
this whole process.
And, in the end, what you end up
with is a different amino acid
and you regenerate your
imine of pyridoxal.
So out of all-- the
only pyridoxal phosphate
requiring enzyme that
goes from the aldehyde,
or imine, to the
pyridoxamine are
these transamination reactions.
And, so, this is the
most complicated.
Normally, at the
end of your reaction
you wind up in this state.
And this probably seems
extremely confusing to most
of you, but after you solve
three, or four, problems
where you have to look at
the actual transformations,
and think about this
tetrahedral chemistry, imines,
and amino groups, and alpha
keto groups, you will, I think,
be able to actually
easily see how
ingenious nature has
been to actually design
pyridoxal phosphate.
And, I think, the most
amazing thing, of course,
is that pyridoxal phosphate
without any enzyme--
I told you can catalyze
many, many reactions you
do all the reactions
with the en-- it does it
spontaneously, at room
temperature, at pH 7.
What the enzyme does, is only
allows one of these reactions
by having everything positioned
exactly the right way
in the active site.
So this is one of
the cofactors, that I
thought was
amazingly cool when I
was in graduate
school, that made
me want to become a biochemist.